but i wanted to see your white pill and
and uh advance you one pill
because there's something i have i think
i've had a realization about about what
the future looks like when it comes to
the conservative population
all these kids
who were forced to wear masks eight
hours a day
day after day after day after day and
hated every second of it and they saw
their mother lose her job because she
wouldn't take the vaccination they saw
their daddy lose his job because he
wouldn't do x y z that the government
man was telling them to do and watch
their lives get destroyed
and watch their their their own person
be violated
over and over and over year after day
after day year after year now i believe
that they grow up and when they become a
voting age they remember
what that was and they go they're not
doing that to my kids i'm not voting for
anybody that would i ever think would
have a shred of a chance of ever
pressing down on us that hard again i
will never vote for them it doesn't
matter how liberal they might be or
whatever they go yeah i'm not voting for
that because this has been a horrific
experience i mean when i got two little
boys you see them little boys putting
mass on their faces see they see it
going in and out and in and out
you go to a basketball game and they're
making kids wearing masks running up and
down a basketball court
child abuse is what that is and that
jacks with their brains i told my boys
you're not wearing a mask to school
anymore all the school said we had to i
said i'm going to send the school a
letter
so you look up online and you go is a
mass considered a is it considered an
experimental medical device
yes it is per the fda a mask is
considered an experimental medical
device when it comes to stopping the
contraction of a virus it is on their
website go look it up okay let's
extrapolate on that then do you have the
permission do you have the authority to
coerce me into using an experimental
medical device no you don't not if i
don't give you permission to well then i
don't give you permission to well you
have to do it anyway or we're gonna
punish you oh you know what that's in
violation of nurnberg code i think it is
go re go read the exact language on that
you are not allowed to force people to
do something against their will anything
medically and and if they don't do it
punish them for it and so i sent a
little letter
and spelled all that out and put the
links on there and highlighted what it
said right off the government websites
and guess what i got five minutes later
an opt-out form oh oh
interesting and opt-out for them they
didn't want to have that fight well
here's well they don't want to have
anything
here's the issue i see
i think there's a there's a rudimentary
um view on masks i think masks work
it's simple if you're gonna cough or
spit on somebody the mask will stop you
from doing it but then there's questions
about forcing everybody even people who
aren't sick to be wearing one you know
we used to see all the time uh people in
asian countries if you get a cold they
put a mask on just so that they don't
cough or spit on somebody
that's simple i mean that's a basic
logic but then they come in and they say
five-year-olds who may or may not be
sick we don't care just they have to do
it and then there's serious questions
about okay well what are you doing to
the the develop development of their
mind if they can't see mouths move if
they can't see human expression while
they're communicating at one of the most
formative years of their lives
when these kids aren't even sick or not
only that but they're substantially less
likely to get sick i can certainly
understand if a parent wants to make a
choice for their kids that it should be
the parents not not the government and
this is why i just say the simple
solution really is getting your kids out
of these schools getting in pods but it
sounds like you found a solution which
was an opt-out form that they
well so i think it goes back to the
point that these these people are
generally bullies
whether it's talking about masking your
kid up or it's talking about grooming
them in a school room or whatever they
are not willing to go the full distance
of what that fight actually looks like
if we've got the backbone to take it
there they don't want to go that far
they don't want to go in a courtroom and
and have a and have a let's go back to
the school that's being taught in
schools hold up the book in front of a
jury read the state and federal statutes
as to what it says about exposing kids
to obscene material then show the jury
the pictures read the jury the book and
ask the jury are they guilty of
violating these statutes they're going
to go of course okay judge what's the
penalty for violating the statute you're
in big trouble why is that why why isn't
it happening though because people are
too afraid to stand up again and that is
the problem with getting too blackfilled
about this stuff your average person
goes around thinking i know that what
they're forcing on me is nonsense but i
can't make a difference but like you
said and like you were able to show in
the situation with your kids in this
school if you stand up to these people
it's not always going to work out for
you 100 of the time but you're never
going to know unless you try and the
problem is nobody's trying yeah it
sounds like the evidence that you
accrued that you sent to them would be
valuable to put public so that other
people could grab the evidence and send
it i have a high school diploma okay
i'm a self-taught i read myself i can
think on my own and i look at this and i
go that's got to be illegal to do that
surely that's illegal well let's just
look and here you go and you can find
volumes of information as to yes your
gut instinct was correct your common
sense proves to be true again here's all
the ways that that's illegal and here's
all the case law to back it up and
here's what happens when somebody breaks
that and you present that to the other
side they do not want to have that fight
out in the open i really appreciate what
you just said a moment ago like i have a
high school diploma there are so many
people who are so overeducated and then
they can't even think to do the simplest
possible thing when it comes to
protecting their own children yeah it's
an indoctrination camp that's a big part
of why public schooling and the college
industry they want you to sit down wait
till you're called on i mean tim dropped
out you got out of high school basically
and then what was your you went to
college you went to an art class i did
yeah i know can you believe it what were
you did you do college lydia no i didn't
you were like homeschooled too for a
long time yeah so i actually started to
take crap uh classes that were the
equivalent of prereqs for nursing
because i really liked biology and that
kind of thing so there was no doctrine
indoctrination there they're just like
here's what's up this is what's really
happening i was wildly indoctrinated
yeah i have to break that mold every day
yeah i'm just ready to say yes and and
follow the leader but i'm it's not what
i want so that's not to fight against it
it's funny because i went to catholic
school from kindergarten until the end
of fifth grade and i wouldn't even call
any of that indoctrinating like they
didn't even do a good job teaching me
about christianity of course not it was
catholics
they teach you how to learn which is sit
raise your hand don't speak unless
you're called on which first of all is
like are you kidding that that's a
stomps on creativity you need to let
kids express themselves and be their
best self
and there's other ways you know wait and
you can only go out you can't leave the
classroom unless you're allowed to go
for iu maybe maybe that's the part of
the drift right so even in a catholic
school
we see them now many of these churches
putting up blm flags yeah exactly stuff
so when i'm a kid
we had religion class you know take out
your religion book at 9 am or whatever
and they wouldn't really actually teach
us about the the the complex ideas
around spirituality faith in the
universe it was kind of just like read
the paragraph
i'll be reading my book again we learned
i'll be collecting my salary at the end
of the week imagine if catholic schools
were as interested in teaching the
students about catholicism as public
schools are at teaching kids to become
transgender right i say this to people
as a catholic if someone has a deep love
for jesus christ and the blessed virgin
and my faith you can't assume that a
catholic school is going to be good for
your kid in most instances in most
instances it won't be i'm a big advocate
of homeschooling uh probably because
i've never done it being facetious i'm
sure it's it's easy for someone who
doesn't have kids but also i know i'm a
huge advocate of homeschooling i think
these institutions are are terrible
there are some really good institutions
you can still find but for the most part
you can't say oh well it's like it's a
catholic school therefore they're going
to teach my kids good things absolutely
so i i grew up in chicago with a fairly
liberal family but my mom still wanted
to homeschool me and my siblings and
then once we i went to i went to
catholic school kindergarten to fifth
grade then public school sixth to eighth
spent a couple months freshman year of
high school and my my parents pulled me
out saying it was bad went back to
homeschooling we did a correspondence
thing where my dad would come in you
know every day and then these are my
parents working my parents were getting
divorced but my dad would come in like
what did you read about what did you
learn ask me questions let's talk about
it we ended up i ended up me and my
brother sped through the entirety of
high school because we could go as fast
as we wanted
and i look at the school system as just
corrupt for a lot of reasons outside of
what they're doing now with the the
creepy conversations with with these
children and they're like we have to
talk about our relationships and our
significant others and i'm like to
five-year-olds that sounds really weird
you know but it's also just really bad
they don't do a good job of actually
teaching kids
if
i i'm i'm i believe
that every human has potential
that if you take a kid from anywhere and
you give them access to knowledge and
you teach them and you show them here's
how you hammer a nail here's here's how
you you know build a bicycle they're
going to learn that i still remember the
cheat code from teenage mutant ninja
turtles 2 on nintendo b-a-b-a up down
b-a left-right b-a stark why do i
remember that because that game was
awesome
i played that game for like a few months
of my life and i'll never forget the
code for level select in that game it's
crazy i got 007 373 5963 is the password
to get to mike tyson and mike tyson
now what if as kids what if as kids
instead of learning that stuff we were
taught something
like language for instance yeah multiple
languages how about what happens when
you go to a school and you got a kid
who's ready to learn and absorb
information and they just waste their
time
they talk about nonsense and politics
these kids are going to grow up without
critical thinking skills and not just
waste their time but groom them yeah and
then on top of that like well let's say
let's say we had public schools which
functioned effectively and were really
teaching kids the things they needed to
be taught the idea that you're going to
sit a kid in a desk for six hours a day
and end up having any kind of productive
outcome from that is insane yeah they
make the smart kids wait like you i used
to stare at the clock and just wait to
be done because i was like what are you
doing um i want to talk about grooming a
little bit because it doesn't have to be
firstly i don't think it has to be
sexual you can groom someone to be a
psychopath to do other bad things and it
doesn't have to be non-parents i think
parents can groom their kids to do evil
things if they're bad people
yeah here's the fascinating thing is
there's this big like the big push now
from the left is they're saying
uh
parents are are grooming kids into
heterosexuality by talking about like
marriage and things like that
and i was like okay let me let me just
make this clear uh the parental rights
and education bill prevents
a teacher from talking to a
five-year-old about traditional marriage
i mean the bill does that and then you
can't encourage the kid to keep it a
secret
so no that's that's a ridiculous
argument it's not happening the reality
is people just like hey i don't want you
talking to my kids about adult content
adult issues also for you to decide one
thing that we just have to be able to
acknowledge is if you think that's even
remotely true your brain just doesn't
work properly telling a child that they
can someday grow up and get married and
have a family is absolutely not
equivalent to trying to encourage them
to engage in sexually depraved behaviors
when they're older or render themselves
experimental hormones but i'm not even
saying i'm not even going that far i'm
taking their position on this where it's
like a guy says
my kids might ask me you know my
students might ask me about having a
boyfriend and it's like yeah that's not
banned you can literally be like yes
it's a photo of my boyfriend now if you
want to understand this but you're a boy
too well maybe you should talk to your
parents and and and they can help you
understand the these these more adult
concepts and the kid will say okay and
that's it and said they're like let me
tell you about all of it that that's
that's not if the kid's confused or
doesn't understand because not exposed
to it you just simply say maybe
something your parents should talk to
you about you know i'm not here to teach
you about that stuff but um you know
it's the guys of education that's all
this is right they are hiding behind the
guys
and the excuse of and the shield of they
think education if you take the same
exact situation same exact scenario same
exact people and you put them out in the
public park or you put them at a mall or
you put them over at somebody's house or
whatever and the same exact thing went
down you would have the right to go
after those people i feel like the the
politicians are wrecking the economy as
under the guise of politics right yeah
they're just a bunch of people that have
done a really horrible horrible thing to
us in the last couple of years i think i
think nancy pelosi joe biden mitch
mcconnell uh they're just they're just
they should have retired a long time
they're passively letting the federal
reserve annihilate our economy it's not
no no i i get that but what i'm saying
in addition to this other stuff i mean
look at what age do you retire from
baseball
you you guys 38 forty one
if there's one thing we've learned to
the left age is just a number yeah
that's true yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
so much you guys remember when i think
it i think it was snapchat had a sticker
that said age uh love has no age
disgusting yeah yeah and then it got
pulled people were like what does that
mean i do believe there's solar age is
how many times your body's been around
the sun but then there's your genetic
age and and some people age
faster and slower depending on how much
damage you're doing to your telomeres my
my point is just simply
in any other industry
all of these people would have retired
not every single one but like pelosi
uh dianne feinstein joe biden come on
you know it's about time they should
have retired 20 30 years why do they
have power i don't understand i mean
it's the system it's the system we built
that our ancestors built that we can
vote a popularity contest to put someone
in forever it's it's the apathy of the
people
we we are too comfortable everything is
too good so people just stopped paying
attention the left stopped paying
attention the democrats not paying
attention and then the woke nonsense
came in and they just adopted and said
fine we'll use it the right stops paying
attention and they let the cultural
institutions get taken over by what left
insanity and here we are that now that's
a tidal wave that's coming though is on
the local level i can tell you right
here in middle tennessee every single
county in middle tennessee
has parents and grandparents who are
running for school board positions
county commissioners you name it all the
way up and down the tickets and they
these guys are running for the hills
they don't know what to do because the
parents are so fired up that the schools
won't listen to them
uh and are just running roughshod over
their rights as parents they're just
going well i'm a stay-at-home mom but
i'm running for the school board my
name's sally vote for me and they're
like i'll vote for you sally no problem
i'm telling you this is happening all
over the u.s
they're gonna they're gonna turn these
little these little local situations
upside down and i don't think they'll
ever get their power back because we we
have been asleep we've been asleep a
long time we just assumed that
we just assumed that uh you know there
got to be good people because they're on
the school board they care about kids
right that that seems like an easy thing
to do yeah but that's not true they had
another agenda as to why they wanted to
be on the school board and now we're all
learning that and so regular old people
are standing up and flipping it around
i'd love to be on my kid's school board
absolutely when your kids like you and
they see you at school it improves their
mood and then they become more popular
and well liked at school that's your dad
that's awesome man you know you know
what works for uh
tim cast our company i i encourage
people and within reason to bring their
kids into work when they can
uh i want i want their kids to see what
work looks like i want them to interact
with adults i think you should treat
kids like adults within reason obviously
you treat it you can cuss in an adult
you can get an argument with them you
can show them certain things you
wouldn't show a kid but you talk to them
on on
on matters age relevant as you if you
were as if they were adults
so if they say hey what is this
if ian said you know how do i how do i
fix the mic i'll be like okay take the
xlr plug it that's the cable right there
i would i wouldn't say to the kid okay
this is a microphone a microphone no no
you just talk to them like normal so
they can learn
i like it when the kids can come in
first of all it's fun
we've got skee-ball we've got a skate
park and i want them to be like this is
exciting i want kids to look up to
success and say if i work hard and and
and i believe in myself i can accomplish
cool stuff too i can be respected i can
have fun and i want them to see real
working adults interact with each other
here's trade here's money being
exchanged here's i need this job done
here's how you help chickens here's how
you clean the floors so that's what i
really like
i think that's infinitely more valuable
than what schools do
my family owned a business when i was a
kid and that's what i saw
i i saw adults talking about politics
they talked to me they didn't care that
i was a kid and they'd be like i just i
got to learn from real people real you
know i can tell you some of the stuff i
tell my boys
uh is you want to play baseball i want
to play baseball i want to be in the mlb
10 years old
i go all right he goes and there's this
bad it's called a marucci bat that's
like the best bat you could possibly get
he's not on the team yet i said
i'll tell you what i'll get you that
marucci bat
you go pick out the best glove that you
want and that's it i can't get you on
the team and i cannot hit a home run for
you and i cannot catch a flat ball for
you you gotta go out in the backyard and
take 100 swings a day on that thing off
that tee you got to get on the team i
can't if you don't make the team that'll
be terrible you know i'd hate it for you
but that's how this goes so here's the
best bat here's the best glove go make
it my dad did that too he got me the uh
martin dreadnought he gave when i was
like want to learn together if you're
going to learn a trade get the best tool
you can for it and that you learn it
with that yep but it's on you to go do
it and there's no lying you're not going
to walk up to the coach and be like i'm
the best player you've ever seen and
he'll be like you're on the team then no
he's gonna be like prove it yeah and you
can only you can only prove it by doing
it yeah when the kid strikes out at the
game you go well how many how many
swings did you take on the t this this
week in the backyard
none he was on your ipad the whole time
right yes what sucks striking out from
all your friends doesn't it
yeah i go well if you don't want to feel
like that again maybe i'll go out there
and swing it but that's on you i don't
care if you're in mlb or not i just want
you to be good at whatever you do you're
gonna be good at baseball go hit go
swing baseball bats and so he goes okay
and so little you're right about kids
people underestimate kids like they
don't understand it they understand
better than most adults because their
mind's not cluttered up with all this
nonsense that we all have it's very
clear to them what you're saying you
should you should treat them with
respect when you talk to them thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you